let's go to the endorsement that Ron
DeSantis God which is a legendary
endorsement you should put this on the
wall by the way somewhere in his office
and he should brag about it at the uh uh
uh campaign anywhere he's going where
he's talking he should bring this up
here we go ready Hillary Clinton
says Rhonda Santos is pathetic and just
trying to get some attention Hillary
Clinton says something like that about
you that is an endorsement that's how I
would take it yes Hillary Clinton
criticized Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
describing his proposal to Grant
resident presidents uh more control over
the Department of Justice as pathetic
and attention seeking during an MSNBC
interview with Rachel Maddow she
commented he's promising anything to try
to get some attention it's kind of
pathetic isn't it the sentence has
previously questioned the independence
of agencies like the doj stating you
can't say that you're independent and
hands-off that that's not the way the
system is designed his press secretary
from this commitment to ensuring uh uh
accountability and Justice and law
enforcement agencies the discussion also
touched on the Republican parties and
race of partisan policy politics within
law enforcement prompting Clinton to
express worries about democracy and the
rule of law particularly given the
lingering influence of trump uh Vinnie
thoughts on this I just like is it just
me or and I want to know from the from
the people and you guys too are you guys
tired of like this Hillary Clinton get
it that nobody gives a damn what you're
saying and she just won't go away do you
know what I'm saying she was on The
Rachel Maddow Show and they were and
besides this one besides the Santas they
were laughing these two were laughing
the two of the biggest liars about Trump
and the indictments and how happy she is
meanwhile she is the biggest getting
away with cheating and murder person
I've ever met in my life and like like
when is enough going to be enough and
she just keeps popping out of the
woodwork and nobody just go away she
would love to run if there's any opening
she would do anything why wouldn't
here's my question why wouldn't you okay
why would why why isn't she running this
time around why isn't she going for the
Gusto I'm with her and all those numbers
why isn't she running oh how do you know
she's not are you sure what I'm saying
to you is never underestimate a person
that since they were in the womb they
wanted to be the president United States
never she she looks at herself as the
world leader she looks at herself as an
Emperor as a president as the queen her
identity is that now whether you like it
or not that is her identity she's
convinced she's above you and everybody
else and she knows what's best to run
the world that's how she views herself
she looks at everybody as beneath them
everybody anybody and everybody she
looks at including her anybody she says
yeah I'm I'm Beneath You're beneath me I
know what's best that's how she views
herself when you're like that any
opportunity so the strategy would be if
you go right now run against Biden
you're going to look like an idiot she
wouldn't run right like do what RFK that
she's above that she's better that's
that's cheap stuff that RFK people would
do in her eyes yeah in her eyes she's
more strategic behind closed doors get a
couple favors use the doj which you know
she's you know to eliminate some
candidates and then she see if she gets
she gets in there are certain people
that are so deceptive they shouldn't
never ever count them out on how they
gain power she's one of those people and
the super delegate game that she knows
how to play behind the scenes which is
sort of a rigged part of the DNC and I
go back to 2008 you could almost just
change the words here Hillary Clinton
2008 just visualize this instead of
pathetic
Barack Obama is inexperienced and just
trying to get some attention this has
been her Playbook yeah well last time
she said that that guy became the
president he did okay well I don't know
if that's necessarily going to be uh the
case this time with our friend uh
Governor DeSantis just to Circle back to
that no but it is her Playbook that's
how she works thanks Tom
um I just to Circle back to the whole
premise of this this is great marketing
campaign uh for DeSantis we all saw the
commercial uh about the trans family
that was leaving Florida for greener
pastures he should use that to his
Advantage yeah okay we you know
everything I've done in Florida so if
you're trying to win a Republican
primary what's more helpful to you than
going to battle with Hillary Clinton if
you're Ron DeSantis so I actually think
this is a net positive for him in the
Republican primary and his numbers have
been fading and fading and fading you
know it was six months ago he was neck
and neck with Trump now it's it's not
even close so maybe this helps did he
did he fire his marketing person and
hire a new person I think he fired his
uh Chief of Staff the third oh yeah it's
it's not it's not good it's not a good
look on what's going on over them by the
way in New Hampshire can you pull up New
Hampshire polls can you can you pull up
New Hampshire polls I think in New
Hampshire polls he's officially behind
Chris Christie in New Hampshire if you
guys haven't seen this uh uh pull this
up to see uh let's see if that shows up
or not and if you're standing behind
Chris Christie nobody can watch this
polls put that's a good point I didn't
even think about that very scientific
that's interesting polls put Christie's
second to Trump in New Hampshire's as
DeSantis Fades yeah
oh it doesn't let you get there I'm
actually I would like to see where
DeSantis is in Iowa I'm not shocked that
Christy is doing well in the Northeast
everyone in New Hampshire New Jersey New
York they kind of they're they're
familiar with him he'll pull well there
I'd like to see what the stats are in
Iowa because that is the first state
correct
show that nine percent likelihood
Christy to the Republican how many
percent to Chris okay let's go look at
Iowa what's Iowa look like do you have
RCP real clear politics
Robin I think I'll let you pull
everything
Real Clear Politics yeah election 20 up
at the top I would assume that DeSantis
is doing way better in Iowa than he's
doing in New Hampshire
okay punch in on that buddy National
National Trump's at 54 Cent this is at
14.
6.7 Pence money has cleared Pence former
vice president well you highlighted it
he's lost he's only he's the only
candidate that's lost Twitter followers
in seven months you got Iowa where
you've got Iowa where it's a little bit
closer than the national average or
DeSantis is at 17 Trump said 44 and then
and this is after this how recent is
this Adam how recent is this uh this is
this today ask ask Malik over here
this is as of a week ago
go back to New Hampshire this is today
yeah and then all right so then DeSantis
so well DeSantis apparently is doing
better than Christy in New Hampshire and
not the shift gear so what Trump these
indictments that are happening Trump's
numbers are actually they they went up
correct they actually went up so my
thing is the left is doing because
apparently he can still run if even if
he's arrested or felon or whatever what
is their angle to boost them up like
this because they think he's easier to
beat than whoever would be behind him I
mean obviously look at the numbers
nobody's voting for anybody else why is
this show in New Hampshire DeSantis
ahead and that article all these
articles are saying that these are these
are compilation polls from Real Clear
Politics and what you're seeing is the
first poll of the week which correctly
is pointing out that there's a shift
going it might just be one pull what's
interesting let's see this general
election match up how much you trust
this Source Tom just
high low Medium real clear politics is
10 to 14 days behind the actual momentum
that's in the market but they compile
everything and if you were to click
through on them so do you trust them or
not
they've been more right than wrong okay
what point is we'll use this as a source
where's the general election
General so it looks like it's a dead
heat with Biden Trump 44-44 yep uh looks
like Biden is doing better uh than
DeSantis 44 to 42. and then what is it
it took the time to see how Trump would
do against Kamala Harris 46-42 but uh
here's what I can guarantee I I'm going
on the record stating this it's going to
be October it's likely to be Trump Biden
okay and what we're going to hear from
the news is race is too close to call
you know it's going down to the wire
right we got to see what's going on in
the three Battleground States
Pennsylvania Michigan and Georgia and
this stat right here has Biden and Trump
at a dead heat 18 months out and that
just boggles not even 18 months out what
are we 14 months out it just boggles my
mind that like still with everything
that's happening with crime border
Ukraine that's just a short list people
are still like I still you know I don't
want somebody that's gonna rock the boat
and they just want this six senile
perverted kid sniffing like it drives me
insane that people still haven't I'm not
woken up to what's happening I'm not
sure
if it is him which it looks like it is
he should show up on an orange jumpsuit
and be like orange is the new orange and
that's how I would debate if I was drunk
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here